the impeachment vote we expected
yesterday is now scheduled for today it
was put off unexpectedly last night
after more than 14 hours of intensely
partisan debate in the House Judiciary
Committee Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler ended the session around 11:15
p.m. Eastern asking members to quote
search their consciences before today's
vote that brought more outrage from
Republicans who spent the day repeatedly
trying and failing to amend the charges
Nancy Cordes is in the hearing room
where the committee will return later
this morning Nancy good morning so
what's behind this delay well
Republicans called it petty and
disrespectful they argued that Democrats
simply wanted more people watching when
they take this vote in response a senior
committee aide told CBS News that they
actually took this pause in the interest
of transparency because they didn't want
to vote on these two articles abuse of
power and obstruction of Congress in the
dead of night I want the members on both
sides of the aisle to think about what
has happened over these last two days
and to search their consciences before
we cast a final votes the committee is
in recess that moved shots and
infuriated Republicans there was no
consulting from the minority ranking
member on your schedule for tomorrow
would you just blown up schedules for
everyone you chose not to consult the
ranking member on a scheduled issue of
this magnitude so typical this is the
this is the kangaroo court that we're
talking about it came after more than 14
hours of bitter debate the idea that
Donald Trump was leading an
anti-corruption effort is like kim
jeong-hoon leading a human-rights effort
oh yes there were crimes well then why
aren't they in this impeachment document
the president states shook down a
foreign power to come and get involved
in our election that's wrong we get it
you don't like him that doesn't mean you
can banish him from the marketplace you
can't send him out of his businesses and
say he can't hold a position of honor or
trust you don't get the right to do that
the people of this country do we live in
a republic
I'm just sick of this the two sides
unable to agree on even basic facts
Donald Trump pressured a foreign
government to target an American citizen
for political gain president Trump
wanted to get to the bottom of possible
corruption with the Biden spur yzma and
ukraine republicans argued they were
being steamrolled by the majority this
committee has now sounded the death of
minority rights in the Senate trial
likely to come the balance of power will
be flipped with Republicans in control
though there could be a clash between
Senate Republicans who want a short
trial and President Trump who wants a
full-blown defense with new witnesses
I'm gonna coordinate with the
president's lawyers so there won't be
any difference between us on how to do
this Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell argued in the end the process
won't matter we all know how it's going
to end there's no chance the president's
going to be removed from office the full
House of Representatives is expected to
vote as soon as next Wednesday and
Democratic leaders are bracing for a few
Democratic defections from moderate
members who are from swing districts who
worry that a vote to impeach could hurt
their re-election chances in 2020 all
right Nancy thank you very much